tu m'as donné de coton tige l'entamé bon
eric non mais je vais être un peu direct
mais le coeur de notre sujet le coeur du
débat se fasse qui est arrivé à ma rage
parle pas d'autres actes incarcération
je parle de votre interpellation le
coeur du débat c'est ce que nous avons
appris au cours de nos échanges nous
avons appris quoi nous avons appris avec
isabelle qui a une montée en gamme de la
violence ce qui autrefois relever de la
violence simple est devenu de l'extrême
violence qui auparavant relevé de
l'extrême violence est devenue de
l'hyper violence
ensuite nous avons appris deux choses en
regardant l'interview du jeune homme
c'est d'abord que les délinquants sont
de plus en plus jeunes vient ensuite
qu'ils n'ont plus aucune peur de la
police le type a évidemment son visage
est flouté ce jeune mais il vous dit si
je dois recommencer je vais recommencer
donc moi je suis pas là pour faire un
débat idéologique je m'en fous que ce
monsieur soit du rassemblement national
je m'en fous que vous aussi vous ayez un
engagement politique
je veux des réponses concrètes et pour
moi la réponse concrète elle consiste à
remettre l'église au centre du village
il faut que la police soit protégé et il
faut que la police dans les zones
dangereuses reprennent l'ascendant
psychologique et physique il faut
changer de mode opératoire peut-être
mais je finis mon raisonnement
la police doit être la force dominante
partout y'a pas des zones où elles
seraient dues à dominante et d'autres où
elle serait dominante donc dans notre
cas précis monsieur je regrette mais
vous êtes encore si vous obtenez ray il
ne vous arrive rien c'est chiant d'être
contrôlé je suis d'accord avec vous mais
si vous présentez vos papiers l' affaire
est close et on n'aurait pas assisté à
cette scène donc remettant la police au
centre du jeu évidemment je me suis même
engueulé avec bruno pomart du temps où
il était invité les violences policières
existe bel et bien une ordonnance non on
s'était en vue policières n'existe pas
moi là vous voyez que je les prends ce
monsieur excusez moi si vous voulez que
les choses changent
mais je n'ai joué que tout le monde y
met du sien si vous pour un truc
complètement anodin vous faites acte de
rébellion vous dit j'ai pas à présenter
les papiers si tu bouges d'un centime
est en mai une fusée moi mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on s'adresse à une journée
nous dans pardonnez-moi de choses il
faut comprendre
quant à policer s'adresse à moi ils me
demandent mes papiers je demande juste
pourquoi est ce que tu me demandes le
papier s'agit pas de quelque chose
ministériel annoncé la police on sait
que c'est l'autorité donné mon féminin
mais maintenant si c'est répétitif
si le police et abuse de son pouvoir
s'il ne part d'une certaine façon s'il
veut montrer qu il est beaucoup plus
fort que moi beaucoup plus puissants
comment la baisse beaucoup plus
intelligents que moi
à partir de ce moment là là il n'est pas
sans carte de policier n'est pas bien
c'est fini et ensuite bien mettez vous
dans la tête car justement policiers
sont exposés à des dangers quotidiens
bien plus important que koné vote
excusez moi ils sont ils sont agressés
en permanence et ensuite il vous protège
ils nous protègent contre tous les gens
qui pourrissent les cas sans aucun
vendeur n'est qu'un agent ne sont
franchement pas du tout mais moi c'est
ce qui est assez dangereux de truqueur
ça va me permettre si vous permet vers
lequel je vous en prie répété plusieurs
fois pour la justice pour tous vous ne
pouvez pas dire aujourd'hui que quand un
policier comme est un acte ou quand ya
un décès il n'y a pas d'enquêté de
sanctions ça fait pas la vérité et quand
vous dites ça vous attisez ces jeunes
justement cathy qui attaquent le
commissariat parce que vous laisser
penser que les policiers auraient tous
les droits
bien sûr qui sont sanctionnés bien sûr
qu'à des enquêtes bien sûr qu'on regarde
et bien sûr que comme tous les êtres de
tous les français ils sont sanctionnés
et encore plus donc ne vous dites
attention en justice pour tous il ya de
la justice pour tous dans la sphère
adama traoré
il ya une enquête il ya de la remise en
cause de la part de la famille des
expertises et cetera et cetera vous ne
pouvez pas dire qu'à pas dans kate qui a
pas de procès cas pas de sanction vous
devez revenir sur ses propos
parce que là vous attisez tous ces
jeunes vous êtes sûrement écoutez là où
vous habitez
et là quand vous dites ça vous engager
ces jeunes a justement à les envoyer des
des projets